when you talk about iconic women in the
rap game your name immediately comes up
Kim what does it mean to be here at the
BT award it always means everything
because I started this is like one of
the you know the network publications
that helped launch my career so it's
like anytime I give a chance to than my
image back to be easy I'm here I'm here
and ready and having fun tell me about
the show what does girls cruise is that
it
tell me about girls cruise girls cruise
is gonna be one of the funnest shows
that you've ever seen on like reality TV
but it's not your average reality
television show you know it's me my
girls I mean my girl chilli like oh my
my best friend Tiffany you know I have
some new lighting like new up-and-coming
girls V and B and my bestie Marc Jacobs
hubby here's what I want to know when
you talk about my and chilli these y'all
are single women who are ready to mingle
what's going to happen on this cruise
and how do gentlemen get involved it's
just a bunch of slide boss girls
cruising across the world on a beautiful
thirty million dollar yacht
will there be love in this thing and you
know it simultaneously I will be also
launching my fifth in studio album self
in the name of my fifth studio album is
called nine the number nine we cannot
wait for the album we can't wait for
girls crews when does it hear July 15th
July 15th will it be scandal - gotta
watch him you can be honest with me
gotta watch him you can tell me the
truth well you know what it's just gonna
be fine we like again it's not your
average it's gonna be we want to do
something very different
all right and tonight you who are you
excited to see tonight you look at the
evolution of rap and you see someone
like cardi B who has kind of walked you
know he's standing on your shoulders in
a sense I always love to see her and you
know she makes me laugh she's fun you
know she's so non offensive I just love
her and then you know I wanted to see
all the new artists nice and the baby
everybody like just I used to make me
smile have fun you go have fun let me
know how let me know how I can get on
that girl's cruise okay
[Music]
[Applause]